[sirens wail]
[plane crashes]
[tense music]
NARRATOR: The attacks
on September 11, 2001
introduced the American
people to a new foreign enemy,
al-Qaeda, a militant
Islamist organization
led by Osama bin Laden.
American intelligence
agencies, though,
had known about al-Qaeda and
its threats since the 1990s.
Yet they failed to
adjust their policies
and share intelligence
that could have
prevented the 9/11 attacks.
Why?
One reason, they
did not understand
how grave this threat could be.
But the anti-Western sentiments
and political volatility
that created the
conditions for al-Qaeda
and other like-minded groups to
rise go back nearly a century.
In 1918, near the
end of World War I,
the Ottoman Empire, which had
ruled Arab lands for almost
500 years, collapsed.
Britain and France stepped in,
dividing the land between them,
forming the modern boundaries
of the Middle East.
Then came the creation of the
Jewish state of Israel in 1948.
Originally, the UN had
intended to partition Palestine
into an Arab state
and a Jewish state,
but the Arabs rejected the
plan they viewed as unfair,
sparking a decades-long
conflict between Israelis
and Palestinians and the
surrounding Arab countries.
Osama bin Laden
would internalize
both European influence
in the Middle East
and the Palestinians' defeat
as great humiliations,
pointing to America's
support for Israel's success.
His grievances with the
US, however, were not
only based in past politics.
They were rooted in
religious ideology.
Bin Laden followed the
teachings of Sayyid Qutb,
an Egyptian thinker credited
with inspiring today's
global jihadist movement.
In the late 1940s, Qutb
spent two years studying
in the US, where
he became disgusted
by what he perceived as the
depravity of American culture.
Qutb longed to reinstate
what he considered
the height of civilization--
seventh-century Arabia, when
Muhammad and Muslim armies
ruled.
How?
Qutb argued all
Muslims must take up
arms against the nonbelievers,
which included any Muslims who
rejected his brand of Islam.
This philosophy would be used
by bin Laden and al-Qaeda
to justify mass murder.
Qutb's personal
story, too, would
become inspiration for revenge.
In 1954, Qutb was
imprisoned for planning
the assassination attempt of
secular Egyptian president
Gamal Abdel Nasser.
In prison, he was regularly
beaten and tortured,
which only strengthened
his resolve to keep writing
and galvanizing his supporters.
Nasser, threatened by
Qutb's rising influence,
had him executed in 1966.
But instead of
killing a movement,
Nasser created a martyr.
Qutb's, story in his
book, "Milestones,"
would become an inspiration
for generations of extremists,
including Ayman al-Zawahiri,
who would go on to become
bin Laden's right-hand man.
Born in 1951, Zawahiri possessed
strong Islamist sentiments
from a young age.
At just 15, he founded
a militant cell,
calling for the overthrow of
the secular Egyptian government.
At 22, he joined the
Egyptian Islamic Jihad,
with the goal of establishing
a theocratic Islamic state
in Egypt.
Like Qutb, Zawahiri would
be imprisoned in 1981
in connection with the murder of
then president Anwar el-Sadat.
Zawahiri, too, would be
beaten and tortured in prison.
But this only strengthened
his extremism.
Just a few years earlier,
in 1979, the Soviet Union
invaded Afghanistan
to aid the communists
in the Afghan civil war.
Bin Laden had been working
to help finance, recruit,
and train Arab freedom fighters.
Known as mujahideen, they had
declared jihad, or holy war,
against Soviet troops
in Afghanistan.
It's during this war that bin
Laden would meet Zawahiri, who
led a faction of the Egyptian
Islamic Jihad after his release
from prison.
In 1989, mujahideen
finally succeeded
in pushing the last remaining
Russians out of Afghanistan.
Emboldened by this
victory over the Soviets,
Osama bin Laden, along with
Islamic scholar Abdullah Azzam,
formed al-Qaeda.
Then, in 1990, Saddam
Hussein invaded Kuwait.
The US sent troops to
its ally Saudi Arabia.
But the presence of foreign
Christian troops in Saudi
Arabia, home to Islam's
two holiest sites
of Mecca and Medina, enraged
Saudi-born bin Laden.
Bin Laden would cite this
grievance as a major motivation
for the 9/11 attacks.
Over the next decade,
Zawahiri and bin Laden
would work closely
together, eventually merging
their two terrorist networks.
Like Zawahiri, bin Laden had
grown critical of the regimes
in the Middle East, who
maintained relationships
with Western nations
and failed to bring
his idea of a properly Islamic
government to fruition.
To counter these
regimes, bin Laden
looked to fight the
United States directly,
believing violence would force
the Americans to withdraw
from the Middle East entirely
and allow groups like al-Qaeda
to take control.
Throughout the '90s, the West
experienced multiple attacks,
including the 1993 bombing
of the World Trade Center,
the bombings of the American
embassies in Kenya and Tanzania
in 1998, and the 2000 bombing
of the USS Cole in Yemen.
While the 1993 World Trade
Center bombing was never
officially linked to
al-Qaeda, the motivation
echoed bin Laden's sentiments.
With so many warning
signs, how then
did the most powerful
nation in the world
fail to anticipate the
9/11 attacks, which
seemed so long in the making?
American law
enforcement agencies
fought amongst themselves and
lacked coordinated intelligence
sharing.
They also failed to fully
appreciate history, how decades
of violence and volatility had
created a powerful movement
of religious
fanaticism and hate,
determined to take
revenge against what
they perceived as the
source of their discontent--
the center of Western
values and power,
the United States of America.
[tense music]